my glee is like okay my glib is the fact
that I'm recording it so as requested
I've been reading comments in the video
and they're like no David you don't
really collect shoes anymore you don't
really have that many kicks so what
shoes do you still have left and as I've
mentioned before I used to be a really
big sneaker head I don't really buy
shoes that much anymore specifically
because I started to realize that a lot
of people just buy shoes just to [ __ ]
buy and you buy me you know you put on
you [ __ ] ugly-ass feet oh by the way
this is my room have you guys seen this
is a lamp these are some of my LeBrons
that I went when I played ball snap
ankles specifically my ankles so instead
of going through every pair of shoe that
I have isn't your shoes so instead of
going through every single pairs of
shoes that I have let's just go through
a few of the pairs that I bought
recently that I really really like I
haven't bought a pair of Jordans in a
very long time just because like I don't
think they're really creating anything
new but that kind of sparks my interest
I'm going outside of Jordans and stuff
like adidas here and there some Nikes
some new balances that I'm trying to cop
right now but a lot of the ones that I
want aren't out of stock so let's go
ahead and get into that all right people
let's talk about the first pair of nmds
that I really really really enjoyed
these are my favorite pair of nmds that
came out in 2017 like I said before not
a lot of shoes really catched my eye and
I and I'm really into basics like black
white graves a lot of these neutral
colors just like my [ __ ] now but in
terms of a black and white shoe I think
for me it's all about the details and
this [ __ ] this shoe is really beautiful
so let's talk about the details in this
shoe that I
you enjoy as you can see just from the
odds that you think it's just a black
and white shoe but it's all about the
detail look this is the small stuff in
the details that I like about this I
understand it's just black and white but
that's why you have to kill in the mood
home and right here in the back as you
can see we got that El Tigre bei bag I
feel like a lot of clothing brands like
to use the whole Japanese aesthetic and
the letters because of the clean lines
and it looks really dope but when you
start incorporating like some Chinese
stuff to it it could kind of come off as
tacky specifically just because of like
these old like kung fu movies back in
the day tainted the Chinese lettering
and all those like douche bag dudes that
have like Chinese tats on the arm that
they don't even know what the [ __ ] it
means other small detail we're talking
about the tagging on the tongue the
leather lace holes it's just a beautiful
shoe I [ __ ] like this a lot it goes with
almost everything that I wear let's talk
about my favorite shoe of all last year
inspired by his own brand he brought
that that that off-white space as and
flare to the [ __ ] air max 97 one of
my favorite air maxes ever made in the
history of all nike air maxes look a
little history about the air mass 97 in
case you guys don't know the original
design of this shoe was designed after
the bullet trains in Japan and I think
the first shoe that ever came out was
actually silver like bullet silver the
reason why air max 97's are super
important to me I didn't grow up with a
lot of money as a kid but one of like
the first like dope name-brand shoes
that I ever got when my parents started
making money in their business was an
inter Max 97 and I believe it was black
and it had neon green so later max 97
obviously holds a really dear place in
my heart and it was actually the first
air max that had bubbles going all the
way through so this shoe is iconic to
the air max line last but not least this
is a shoe that a lot of people have just
because of the hype around them you guys
are already know Kanye West and a shoe
line in the easies eye I cut the bread
color way of the supply
50s Kanye West you may have lost your
mind but I gotta say when it comes to
some of the shoes that you've made I
really really do think that you are a
fashion icon my favorite Easy's of all
time though had to be the the turtle
doves that came out used to own them I
sold them because I was like you know
what I'm done with wearing all these
shoes just sell them take the money and
spend it on other things I made a
mistake
I miss those turtle doves man yo anybody
got a hook up to a turtle doves that's
like something I could afford please
hook me up cuz I miss him oh I miss him
so much different well there you guys go
those are my top three favorite shoot
cops of 2017 as I mentioned before I
haven't really bought that many shoes
but when a shoe sticks out to me I just
got to go up there and Trump I don't
like you I don't like you at all but
that's about it people it's like 10
o'clock I gotta get ready to go to sleep
and you know whack one off robot that
was a really immature joke and I'll see
you next time
the more you know so instead of going
through like every shoe that I have I do
remember I haven't done this no one you
know
does this look like a casting couch
video to you that ha it kind of does on
the nest a little bit hi is that the
actual be a pepperoni I order
[Music]
- that's my joke that's mine what what's
your joke alright let's go take it off